foreign
it's great to see everybody come out
this is an amazing event we have Whitney
wolf heard and Katrina Lake
we're going to do a fireside chat and
then we'll do about 20 minutes or so of
q a
just a couple people I want to thank I
want to thank the Bumble team Caroline
Sam and Laura for all the work you all
put into making this event happen and
then this is a co-sponsored event with
the entrepreneurship club and Rama spent
so much time on this so thank you
yeah
and with Wim and Samina who's going to
be coming out in a second I mean there
was a lot that went in behind the scenes
but most of all I want to thank Whitney
and Katrina for taking time out of their
schedule to be with us today uh every
time I hear either one of them speak I
get so inspired and Whitney was in class
today and it was amazing so really
looking forward to today and with that
I'll introduce Samina who's going to
give the bios of our guests
[Applause]
the parent company that operates Badu
fruits and Bumble three of the world's
fastest growing dating apps worldwide
in 2014 wolf heard launch Bumble to
challenge the Antiquated rules of dating
and create a space where people can find
healthy and Equitable relationships
bubble is the only dating app where
women make the first move the company
launched Bumble BFF in 2016 for
friendship finding and launched Bumble
biz for professional networking in 2017.
in January 2020 wolf heard welcome
Blackstone has bumble's new majority
owner with a shared vision of growth for
Badu and bumble in 2021 wolf heard
LED bumble's IPO as youngest woman ever
to take a company public
has previously been named to Time
magazine's 100 most influential people
Forbes 30 under 30 the Bloomberg 50 and
in stylist 50 women who are changing the
world
she's been featured on the cover Fast
Company Forbes and wire
and in 2021 bummel was named as one of
Apple's apps of the year
she is currently on the board of
directors of Imagine entertainment and
on the Executive Board of her alma mater
SMU please join me in welcoming Whitney
Wolford
thank you
[Applause]
moderating this fireside chat we have
Katrina Lake a dear friend of Whitney
Stanford and Wim many of you may
recognize Katrina who is a keynote
speaker at Women's banquet last year we
are so happy to have her back
Katrina's success is a successful
entrepreneur best known as the founder
and CEO of Stitch fix an online personal
styling service revolutionizing the
white people shop
Lake founded Stitch fix in 2011 and took
the company public in 2017 at age 34.
it's not often we have two successful
entrepreneurs on the stage at once let
alone two trailblazing women who also
happen to both be friends partners and
mothers
please join me in welcoming Katrina
[Applause]
all right hi everybody
it's great to be back and it's great to
welcome Whitney we were just talking
about Stanford she was asking me what
years I was here and I feel like this is
like my happiest place on Earth so I'm
very happy to be here and very happy to
be here with Whitney Whitney and I are
good friends we were just talking about
how we need to have some cocktails and
talk about our kids in the public
markets and all that good stuff
um and it's really it's meant so much to
me a lot of this job as an entrepreneur
as a public company CEO is it's really
hard and to be able to have somebody
like Whitney to be able to call and cry
to and like text late at night and
complain to has like meant the world to
me so I feel really just appreciative to
have you in my life with me thank you
well I feel the same way about you so
Katrina when we were going public was so
incredibly supportive so helpful so
inspiring you know she kind of passed
the Baton to me and you were just so
warm and welcoming and I think a lot of
people don't fully appreciate how these
bonds Behind These companies really keep
us afloat right and so everything you
said thank you I Echo that and very
excited to be here I did not and would
never have gotten into Stanford so this
is a very important day for me
unlike Katrina who was very much a
student here but thank you for having us
many many years ago all right
um I have this list of questions Whitney
just said I can ask her anything so get
after it so I'll try to stick to the
script and we will have time for a q a
later so definitely kind of noodle and
questions that you might have
um I mean maybe at a high level I think
like you know both of us have had a lot
of challenging moments and I think
resilience is you know one of the
attributes that helps entrepreneurs to
get to where we are and so maybe it'd be
helpful to kind of share a couple of
those moments of what were some of the
hard ones and what was kind of the
resilience that got you through it yeah
no I think you know better than anybody
what goes into getting a company to
where we've gotten our businesses to
today and there are more lows than highs
candidly as you know and
but what really keeps us going I think
is our mission and our customers and our
teams uh you know when you and I spoke
when I was going public you had so much
good insight and so much
um you know kind of great advice and you
just said keep that game time Spirit
like keep your team happy just make sure
your team feels supported and I think
that has been fuel for me too when
there's days I'm like I'm out of here
what am I doing I can't
um then I just think about everybody
else and the you know the people we're
serving and and you just take a deep
breath right you have three little boys
I don't know how you do that I have two
little boys and I'm confused how I'm
doing that so also our boys are friends
this week
very cute we still have one of Bobby's
trucks actually oh you do you return it
yeah oh wow that's very good Parenting
by the way holding them accountable I
like it um no but I think you know how
have you done it I mean it's like we
just kind of go day by day right I mean
it's the only way you can do it one foot
in front of the next I mean maybe that's
not on the list but I mean I'd love to
hear just what you're you know being a
CEO is such a lonely job and to your
point there are so many times when you
have to get the team you want the team
to be focused the team to be optimistic
and the team to be in one place while
your head can be in another like how
like how do you navigate that element of
the job that can be so lonely yeah well
I don't know if you'd agree with this
but I actually do equate it to Parenting
it's very similar there's days when
you're parenting and you don't have the
answers
um you too want to go take a nap and you
know you're very stressed but you have
to kind of put a brave face on and think
about how you're showing up for you know
in that instance children but in our
teams for everybody else and so there
have been so many days where I didn't
know if we were going to make it through
you know some crazy thing comes out of
left field and
candidly I'm terrified in that moment or
I don't know the right answer but I
think
um kind of just taking a deep breath and
reminding ourselves like you know what
can go well from here like how do we
just find our way out of this and you
know you and I were just talking about
this it's like
there's always a way out there's always
a path through and so I think just
focusing on you know what are the
solutions like what's the you know
choice a and choice B to get out of here
yeah
um maybe one question around just like
you know both of us were raising money
at a time that unfortunately is still
true where I think it was you know much
more difficult for women to raise money
than men and the Dynamics unfortunately
haven't shifted a lot I think even last
year the data I have here is that women
were still only 1.9 of overall funding
um last year which is you know the year
um so you know in what ways
you know in what ways do you feel like
that the dynamic is like
I don't know what is my work question
here like it's super disappointing
obviously like what are some of the
things that you feel like are
disappointing about it and maybe on the
flip side like what are some of the
things that like give you optimism give
you hope like you know kind of help us
to I don't know see the bigger picture
and be able to not be so sad about that
it well it is scary when you look at the
statistics another scary statistic is
that you were the youngest woman to ever
take a company public you waited several
years and then I became the youngest
woman to ever take a Pump Company public
and I'm still waiting to do what you did
which was kind of past the torch and it
makes me sad that I'm still waiting I'm
like where is that next woman that I can
say maybe right here in this room
probably most likely
um and so like hurry up come on guys
I I do think that that's just a
testament to where we're at like things
are moving slower than we would like I
do think that
there is a shifting narrative around the
woman customer and that means money is
going to change I think for the first
time in my career I've seen people start
to kind of raise the flag on women's
health matters and fertility is a really
challenging Journey for so many women oh
and the menopause market so there's all
these markets that people are like
discovering but you know they've all
been here in front of our face and so I
think this is kind of what happened to
me with Bumble it's like I said ooh
women in dating like we matter too and
that was like a shocking Discovery like
we had like discovered some rare Earth
mineral and you know I think that that
the more that this starts to shift the
more money should start to change hands
so I'm hopeful that with the emergence
of like femtech and kind of all of
um the needs around the woman customer
will hopefully diversify you know money
going to those products and candidly
it's businesses like yours and like mine
that
that set the stage for investors too oh
wow there was money you know I can't
tell you how many investors texted me
the day we were going public saying hey
like how do I get in on your um DSP or
like do you know be able to get in
before the thing happens I said um
believe in me three and a half years ago
when I told you about this idea and you
didn't think it was good that's how so
you know I think that we just have to
have more positive examples as well yeah
and that's a good segue to like I used
to have journalists who um like told me
I was like is this a compliment they
would be like oh you know I would ask
people like which company did you
totally Miss on and like the one that
I've heard most often was Stitch fix I
was like okay cool so what company most
passed on out there but um
but I mean but it's interesting but in
some ways it's interesting because you
say also that you are underestimated
people didn't see it and so like you
know many people in this room may end up
becoming investors like what advice do
you have for that
um think different right we have to
challenge the way we see something in
order to actually be willing to see it
if that made any sense that was like a
weird Riddle That was not supposed to
happen that way but the point is like
you know if we just look at everything
that came before there's no way to see
anything beyond that and so I think
Bumble was an example of that because
there were so many dating apps out there
and everyone was like this Market's too
saturated there's no way how could it
but we were looking at the woman's view
the woman's lens and so I think the more
we kind of Chase the feminine just from
a tech standpoint right it's been such a
um
it's just been such a I don't mean male
dominated just in terms of Workforce or
in terms of capital I think the products
the consumer Brands themselves have been
so oriented
um just without even thinking about a
broader lens or inclusivity or diversity
and I think the more we can kind of
bridge that Gap I think the the
environment will change yeah totally and
I would extend that yeah I think and you
just said it too around like it's I
think it there's so many groups that are
underrepresented in terms of decision
makers and I think any place that like
there's an advantage in being able to
have a better pulse on what people want
and have a better pulse on the true
demographics of who consumers are and so
um hopefully we'll see more of that come
to life I do think though leaning into
being underestimated can actually be
so so so beneficial
it gives you the opportunity to kind of
like fly under the radar competitors
don't put spend into you know cycling
your growth and people aren't watching
you and when you're not being watched
and you're not being you know kind of
analyzed then you get to just run and I
think that that was something that
probably happened to you as well but
with with us people kind of just laughed
at us for so long that I don't think
they saw us as a real threat and by the
time we were a visible threat it was the
horse had left the barn it was just too
late and so I think there is something
about being underestimated and I like it
I actually think it's it's great and it
gives you something I don't want to say
operate to prove people wrong and it's
not that's not the point but it it does
drive me on a personal level when people
tell me no I'm like oh really
and so it's it's like motivating you
know it's exciting to go and do it
differently
um speaking of visible maybe
um like going public like how
how did you arrive at the decision to go
public how has that Journey been
um what how have things changed since
being public
um I could ask you the same thing uh I
think you and I probably arrived at the
decision to go public in similar ways I
would assume I think when you scale a
company to a certain point of Revenue
into a certain growth rate you know
you've got very few choices right as you
and I were discussing it's like do you
raise more money do you sell some of the
company or do you
bring the public along in your journey
and for me on a personal level I was
just saying this in Graham's class
before this that I think it's exciting
to be able to invite the customer along
with your company right not just to like
be a member of bumble which by the way
I'm gonna
pull this room I hope everybody here
either is on Bumble or will be in the
next hour
so that's an expectation I have here
but I think it's exciting to bring the
public Along on your journey I mean if
people I this is so funny the year we
went public we went public on the 11th
so just shy Valentine's Day we saw all
of these tweets of people saying like I
don't want chocolates this year for
Valentine's Day I want Bumble stock and
it was like for the people that they had
met on Bumble and so I just thought that
was cute that you know anybody can be
involved and be a part of the
entrepreneurial journey to some degree I
thought that was exciting yeah but I
don't know if I feel the same way two
years later
one of the downsides what are hard I
mean we could talk about this for the
whole hour so you don't need to list all
the things but um I think you know very
well you know ramping up for earnings
calls every 90 days is
um it's just a week of your life that
you don't get to focus on the company
and meetings that you really wanted to
have about new product or new marketing
initiatives or whatever you've got going
on like those have to get pushed and you
have to just like get so focused and so
in the zone so there's something
exciting about that and I kind of love
it but then on the flip side it is
um you know it's just this beat that
like kind of controls your Cadence a bit
mm-hmm
how do you feel
yeah I think it's and I I mean I also
think that like what you said earlier
around like you know when you're under
the radar and you can just like run I
miss that a little bit too because I
think it's harder there are a lot of
ways in which it's harder to take risks
when you're public that um it's not
impossible but it's just harder you can
bring your investors along and you can
do all those things but
um you know there's some of it is
Regulatory and some of it is actually
just like you're making commitments
every single quarter around what you're
what you're going to do and
um and you know Innovation doesn't kind
of move at a super predictable quarterly
pace so I agree with that no for sure
and there's not a lot of room for
anything to go wrong like war is
breaking out or all of these
circumstances that pandemics you know
there's so many macro
um you know factors that I think
that's another thing for us to worry
about at night and that that becomes
probably more stressful in a public
company than in a private one yeah and
how have you found just kind of leading
a company in this year where
the last I mean what four years right
where suddenly in the workplace we're
talking about racial Justice we're
talking about
um I mean we're talking about women's
rights we're talking about
um War we're talking about you know
people's health and safety with covid
like what how has this leadership
Journey been over the last four years
uh I would say that
every year has its own crazy curveball
right
um but I think for me
I
I'm trying to see all of these
circumstances as opportunities for
growth right that's you could either be
stressed out by it all and underwater or
you'd be like oh it's another big wave
like let's just figure out how to write
it and make it work and keep everyone
safe and happy so that's the only
perspective shift I
I I can really think of that will make
this exciting and invigorating and a
growth opportunity versus just getting
hit by something new every single day
and so I I really think I've tried to
just train myself on perspective because
whether it's covid or the Ukraine war or
if it's
um you know even on a more granular
level with our business the very
unfortunate reality of being in a
business that connects people is for
every amazing success story we have
you read something that makes you sick
and that you know could quite literally
bring me to my knees every day or I can
say okay here's a learning here's a new
product feature we can engineer to
prevent this particular situation from
happening again so almost like using the
the tragic moments macro or granular you
know kind of as a pretentious to our
business as moments for Innovation and
for doing things better and progressing
yep that's all you can do love it
um and maybe just in terms of just like
Bumble and one of the things that I've
Loved about Bumble is I feel like it's
um like it's not just an app I feel like
it's a brand and it means something and
I love that it also I feel like Beyond
just you know kind of connections and
dating that it's also like stood for
female friendship and I feel like in
some ways it's kind of like I see it's
an extension of your personality but
like I mean can you talk a little bit
about just you know how yeah like how
you think about Bumble as a brand how
you think about how like you know how
you can bring it to life you know in
terms of like a mission and something
that people wake up for every day that's
not just about you know kind of like the
and our tactical one thing in the app
right
um well and I feel that about Stitch fix
with you it's interesting I think there
really is DNA from Founders founding
teams the people that are so intimately
involved in birthing these products you
kind of can see you know it's almost
like you know they say dogs start to
look like they're oners it's like these
products start to kind of morph into
whoever is leading them and so I tried
to when we're you know doing our brand
building and when we're launching bff or
when we're launching these new
initiatives I really do try to put an
extreme emphasis with the creative teams
behind it to
be very careful about how it's showing
up in the world is it kind connections
is it our mission is it our values
because
um bumble has always from day one you
know been more than just a dating app in
in my mind personally I've from the very
first moment Bumble was kind of agreed
to you know be be built or created even
under a different name it wasn't even
Bumble at the time it stood for
something bigger than whatever even it
is today and so I still think there's
such Runway and I think there's a
message here for anyone that does want
to start a company don't just think
about like you said the Tactical like
okay the product works this way a b and
c it's like who is this person if this
product was a person who are they do
they make you feel good about yourself
do they leave
positivity everywhere they go or is it
negative is it toxic or is it kind is it
safe or is it dangerous and you know I I
just really think
companies have
personalities and spirits and there's
like a soul to these Brands and so be
thoughtful about it right I was obsessed
with every little detail of The Branding
on day one because that stuff matters
it's like the code of its existence for
the next however many hopefully
you know dozens and dozens of years to
follow I love it I now I love that
notion of like I don't know if I thought
about it that way of like If This Were a
person like what was it like I love that
um are there examples like tactical
examples I guess of just like as an
example of Stitch fix like I feel like
we would try to say like let's look at
everything through the lens of our
values which is maybe a slightly
different take but and it's like how a
performance reviews be done differently
or how would this be done differently
and like what are some of those for
Bumble what are the things that like you
know that you do things in a way that
like only Bumble could do it yeah so I
our tagline at our ink level is kind
connections and um I to your point I
think asking ourselves a new product
feature or a new marketing campaign is
this kind connections is it actually
that or is it something else that we're
trying to make fit here and I do think
this will be the beginning of kind of a
broader decision-making process that we
run which is if it's not kind
connections just don't do it and anybody
here can apply that to any business they
start whether it's uh you know it could
quite literally it could be any business
in the world having that simplistic
whether it's a mission or a tagline or
an ethos whatever you're going to
subscribe to and just say is it actually
this right is it actually organic is it
actually expires and so I think it's
really important and to your point you
probably make changes all the time
you're like oh wait this isn't in line
with our values or this could be more in
line with our values and it kind of
keeps you on the track totally and I
love that I mean you're even
trying to figure out what you're not
going to do I feel like is actually one
of the hardest parts of like being an
entrepreneur and someone who has lots of
ideas and lots of exciting things and so
I love even using it as like okay like
let's use this as a lens to figure out
what we're not going to do yes yes I
think process of elimination through
Mission through who you want to be is
really strong because I think you you
and I are in very similar boats when we
have this type of scale
the world is literally your oyster you
can work with anyone you can team up
with any brand you have access
Beyond you know our early founding
wildest imagination and so I think when
you're starting your company it's like
what can we do what can we do we'll do
anything we'll take anything that we can
get and now it's really about being
extremely protective and very
um very precise about what not to do
yeah right because the the to do stuff
will just run a huge list totally and on
the two decide I mean what are some of
the things that you're working on that
you're excited about things that you
want everybody to sign up for besides
just signing up for humble in general
so I was very sad in the last class that
we were just in I asked everybody who
had a bumble profile and it was not as
many people as I would have liked so
how many people in this room are on
bumble
okay this is better
so broadly anchored over here so I'm not
sure if they're doing this to be polite
because they're closer to me but
everybody needs to download Bumble and
bumblebff right Beth
so Bumble BFF for those of you that are
not looking for romantic connections
friendship is something we all need and
that really is a big focus of mine in
2023 I think everybody here probably on
a personal level or on a more macro
level understands how serious loneliness
is right now I think we've seen the
devastating reports that you know teen
girls one in three of them have had
very serious mental health struggles
with social media and all that so I
think my 2023 the things I'm excited
about
to the point that you were just talking
about is what is kind connections how
does that come to life further so how do
we safety by Design every single thing
in our product I mean there should not
be one thing that we do at Bumble that
is not safety by Design inclusivity By
Design the gender conversation is huge
for us I mean think about it we started
a company where women make the first
move this was in 2014 when me too had
not happened time's up had not happened
there was no conversation around gender
it was really early and so I think 2023
is about what's the next iteration of
that Beyond this kind of binary women go
first product offering and
furthering our efforts around
legislation so in 2019 we passed our
first law which makes sending
unsolicited lewd images illegal it's now
actually illegal in California Texas
several other states and we're working
on the federal version of that so also
looking at AI right AI is happening it's
going to be a bigger part of our
business I'm sure it's a huge part of
your business already how do we keep
that from being harmful towards women
and marginalized communities and so
really just being obsessed with
engineering kind connections and
everything we do and then you know
really making sure that Bumble BFF
scales into this friendship space that
we think is enormous a lot of other
things but trying to stay sane yeah I
love that no I think I mean this I love
the concept of investing in friendship
and I think it is such In This Moment In
Time It's Like It's always important but
it's just like more important than ever
and
who better to lead it than you I you uh
every day and um how about how
I'm actually very curious about AI in
your world I like how you're trying to
turn the tables here this is a
conversation
this is not a monologue so
um I'm actually very curious about AI is
has that already been a huge piece of
how you serve you know yeah I mean it's
so interesting because
um I yeah like it has so many people now
are talking about just from chat gbt and
generative Ai and just like so many
people now are talking about like in our
world everybody's talking about what's
your AI strategy and whatever and I mean
it's interesting because Stitch fix in
some ways has been an AI strategy at the
beginning we have a stylist it's like a
you know it's and now there's like more
formal words for all of these but it's
like you know human in the loop with AI
and machine learning and so that's
always been what we've done
um and so it's it's interesting because
in some ways it commoditizes what we've
been what we consider to be one of our
core capabilities and so in some ways
that can be a little scary but on the
other side it's actually really exciting
because it suddenly just makes like
so much we spent you know we we had 150
data scientists working on things that
now you could just kind of plug and play
and use you know we have the efficiency
it's more efficient and I think that the
valuable thing is the data set which you
guys have too right like I think you can
it's garbage and garbage out with data
like you know a model needs a data set
that's really actionable and really
accurate and helpful and so like we
still have this proprietary data set and
we've already built a lot of things on
it and I think actually a lot of what's
happening in AI now is actually going to
help us to like move faster I think in
some ways but
um but it's interesting because there
are things like like we already had like
a guided stylus note so The Stylist
could
um like you know so we could help The
Stylist with memory as an example where
it's like hard if a stylist is working
with the same client for a long time to
remember something that happened nine
fixes ago and like we can surface that
kind of stuff and so we had already kind
of started doing some things like that
um that now I think in some cases we
don't have to home grow all of the AI
development that we've been doing that
we can plug in and so but it's
interesting it's a very interesting
conversation that we have because like
now and one thing on the public side
that's actually really helpful is that I
do feel like there are times when there
are people in the public markets who
would kind of be like these 150 data
scientists like but what do they really
do like does this like really help your
business or not and like now people like
get it and um and so that's so you know
so largely I think it benefits our
business and it's really exciting that I
think something we've been excited about
for 11 years is like now something that
the general Public's excited about but
yeah I think it's very validating and
also your brand is front and center with
this so I actually think there's an
opportunity for the public to actually
understand
what Stitch fix power and superpower is
in a more tangible way because you know
to to the you know kind of
um
average consumer out there
AI would have been such foreign language
last year and so I think this is
probably really helpful it's interesting
in addition to I mean in addition to AI
what are some of the other like really
big picture themes of things that you're
seeing that are kind of changing the
business landscape or things that are
that you're thinking about in terms of
like the long-term strategy of bumble
um so I think we think about our
business in kind of three key buckets
which is our dating products right so
that's Bumble date the one that you all
know and will have on your phone today
um so that's that product fruits Badoo
and then our next bucket is really
um kind of build or buy strategy so what
is out there that we could buy that is
um you know additive to the relationship
environment not even just a core dating
product but what what extends that user
life cycle what adds back to the Bumble
ecosystem and then the third category is
um really kind of this foray Beyond love
so bumblebeeff is our prime example Biz
is still there but it's kind of taking a
back seat to BFF at the moment and then
really anything that we can kind of use
around kind connections
um but platonically and you can imagine
that can extend into a lot of different
verticals but I think really just being
obsessed with our customer and letting
them lead us as well I think there's a
huge opportunity around breakups you
know a lot of people come back to Bumble
after they've gone through something
tough so how can bumble have your back
not necessarily AI necessarily start to
finish but have this kind of kind bebot
of sorts that can have your back through
all of your relationships right through
finding friends through navigating
nights out with your friends to going on
first dates to making your profile
better after you've gone through a
breakup and you're feeling a little
insecure all the way to finding your
business opportunities and maybe you
know starting your company
and then the the kind of The Next Step
so what can we do with success stories
there's such an opportunity I mean I get
tagged in Bumble weddings
and it's like you know the wedding
planners are integrating Bumble into all
their weddings and so there's just a lot
of different adjacencies and I think
it's a good message for anybody that
wants to start a business is what's the
LTV of your customer and where can you
go with your customer beyond your core
offering because sometimes maybe 10
years from now that will be more
interesting than our core dating product
who knows yeah okay I see Grandma if
you're covering are you cutting us off
we'll move to q a okay so if you have a
question raise your hand we have a
number of Runners who are going to run
the mics too but before we do that let's
give uh Whitney and
[Applause]
[Music]
um where's our where's our mic runners
okay there you go
all right um thank you so much for
speaking with us it's really a privilege
here from someone who's just had such an
impact on advancing equality for women
um so question for you what do you think
the next phase of dating will look like
and how do you think it's going to
impact gender Dynamics between men and
women
great question uh so I think we are
in the swipe era right now right so when
I somehow landed in this dating land
um we were in the match eHarmony era
where you in order to online date you
had to
um
be a certain degree of creepy at that
point
um perceives yes perceived by Society
standards and you had to fill out crazy
forms digital forms like you had to
essentially hand over your blood type to
figure it out and then you know when we
launched Tinder it kind of
threw all of that out the window and was
like who's right here around you you get
to see photos and you say yes or no
and we all saw the you know consequences
good and bad of that
um and then when I launched Bumble it
was really like wait a second even
through all of these dating phases the
woman has been completely ignored in all
of this and women are treated like
second-rate citizens offline and online
in the digital uh dating and offline
dating world so it was all about women
and now I think
we're moving into this
space of people really wanting to
connect Beyond just looks and want to
people want to have that magic moment
that lock eye moment but I don't think
we're going to get rid of our phones and
I don't think we're going to go back to
you know just waiting for that perfect
person to sliding door Style walk in
front of us so I think it's going to be
a hybrid of
how do we make online dating more
trusted safer more accountable and two
how do we let people's personality
and kind of intangible Beyond a screen
shine through and so I think if you can
Imagine The Innovation around those two
opportunities I think that's the next
level of everything so pro-social
Behavior a lot of more accountability
safety kind of woman first approach but
in a way that feels more
um
more personal than just a photo sorry
that's probably really vague but that's
all I can tell you
thank you both so much for your time
um Whitney you have spoken earlier about
how when people underestimate you you
use as an opportunity and previous
interviews you had also talked about how
when you receive a no rather than being
disappointed you use that to be
motivated what are ways that you've
trained your mind to have this type of
positive grit when facing rejection
oh great question
um you know I
I think it's very simple
you have to believe in yourself you have
to even when others are unwilling to and
even when you struggle to do it it has
to start with you
it's so easy for everyone around you to
dismiss you so we have to be our own
biggest Advocate we have to and it's
funny you know I'm in this business of
relationships but candidly the most
important relationship we've got is the
one with ourselves and so you know let
everybody around you tell you no let
everybody around you
not believe in you that's okay if you
become so strong in yourself which by
the way I'm not always strong in myself
right like there are days where I have
zero belief in myself
but that's part of it you have to have
compassion as well for for those
feelings so I think it all starts with
just believing in yourself and letting
you know let everybody else follow
that's what makes a real innovator and
so I think you know you just got to let
everybody do their own thing you can't
control them only you
hi thank you so much for coming in and
speaking with us I'm Emily
um I really loved what you said about
how the business is the people and how
you craft like a personality for Bumble
I'm curious how you came up with your
strategy for hiring and specifically
maybe young Talent the people right at
the beginning that were making Bumble
what it would be and now also after
going public and obviously managing so
many people who make a bumble yeah
um great question so I think early on
and not to make her feel awkward because
she will feel awkward when I do this but
Caroline who's in the front row she's my
first hire ever at Bumble so she's a big
part of the DNA of the company and I
think when I met Caroline
I could see values and attributes in her
that I would want to see in the company
kind thoughtful hard-working
she was just kind of the Perfect Blend
of a good human and so I really tried to
just look for good humans that had
potential so actually it's interesting a
lot of the folks that I hired early on
they would not have gotten jobs off of
LinkedIn like no one would have hired
them based on a series of just random
criteria but my god when you spoke to
them and when you just got in their mind
for two minutes you're like you've so
much potential so I think really looking
for potential Beyond just resume is so
important early on but you need a hybrid
right you have to have the resume for a
lot of these real kind of more
structured roles whether it's legal or
Finance whatever and then as you scale I
think you don't want to swing the
pendulum 100 one way or another you know
it's still really important to me that
we hire people that bring the magic even
if they're not you know 30 years tenured
at 20 amazing companies like you need a
blend and so I think you know you just
have to kind of deal with the needs of
the business as it goes I mean Katrina
I'm sure you've dealt with this all
along I mean you have to have you have
to strike that right balance because too
many professional people will Kill the
Magic this is the truth too many smart
people ruin things no seriously you have
to have some people that are willing to
just operate off of a gut and then you
need the really smart people to keep
them in check
I don't know who's calling on who I I
it's me oh that's the question
um thank you so much for being here
today and my question is two-part so who
are some of the mentors or the role
models that you looked up to when you
first started your Bumble journey and my
second question is now as a successful
entrepreneur what are some ways in which
you're supporting or bringing in more
women into the tech and business space
um so Katrina and I I like I know
that's like an easy thing to point to
the person asking you questions but no
really truly Katrina was the role model
for me I mean reading your articles
saying your stories like I could do it
because you did it and you did it in
such a way that I was like oh my God
like I'm inspired it makes you want to
run faster you have to have a role model
to be able to
make it you know you have to and the sad
reality is as much as I'd love to say
there was a thousand katrinas there
wasn't I mean you were the one and only
and so
um you know Katrina still to this day
you still are my role model I'm like
very you know shocked that I get to be
on a stage with you I mean that
sincerely like I really admire you and
um I think you've been an incredible
example of giving back because she did
not have to take my call when we were
going public she did not have to respond
to me she's busy she's a lot going on
but you were so willing to and you were
so humble and so generous with your time
and I think that's something I would
like to be better about because
I get caught up in the like
I have all these high priorities in the
day and I have these kids that need me
like I don't have time for 15 minutes
with this person trying to start a
company and I have to stop doing that
and I'm really trying to get into
actually have carved out one day a month
on a Friday where it's a free day but
it's not a free day for me it's a free
day for people that want mentoring you
do a sensational job of this she does on
her Instagram you should all follow
along but I do think like you just have
to make time because it's easy once
you've made it past these hurdles to
just like keep going forward and I think
you have to continue to go backwards to
help the next people along the way so
thank you for inspiring me to do that
and I'm going to do a better job of that
well it goes both ways and I um I mean I
so admire everything you've done and
it's funny because now I feel like you
were calling me about public now I call
you Bill I'm Bill Gurley on my board
recently I told Whitney this like like
sent me their earnings call and was like
you should listen to this and these are
all the things that I thought were
awesome about it that you should borrow
and so
um it's really cool to have the tables
turned and the one thing I would just
add to it just because I do feel like
the public narrative around it is so
different is that like my experience of
the women that we get to reach out to
and connect with as mentors is that it
is like a thousand percent people
helping each other and I feel like
there's this kind of like nasty
narrative around like women being super
competitive or blah blah blah that like
I feel really lucky that I haven't
experience and I really do think like
you know we all I felt so supported and
so felt like people are going above and
beyond and I know you feel like it never
feels like it's enough but just know
that like you know I know that you've
given back in those ways too and I do
like I think it is one really special
part about kind of the Unity that we get
to be part of albeit it's way too small
but I do feel like it's one that like I
really appreciated how supportive people
have been power female friendship it's
really important
um no I agree with you I think that's
that's absolutely right
hi I'm I'm Shane thanks so much for
coming right here hi oh my God these
lights are blurry I can't see what
anything is dead
um I'm curious like I think some would
say that something that's really unique
about your product is if you do your job
really well then potentially you would
be on the app for a short period of time
which I know not every relationship is
like that but let's say in a typical one
so I'm just wonder like how you think
about that problem of like success means
that actually like potentially less
engagement yeah it's honestly a
fantastic question it's the first
question that every investor asked me
when we were going public
so the day we were wire framing Bumble I
wrote several words on a board but one
of them was churn and churn is
um
a guaranteed part of a dating app you're
going to have churn but how could we
tweak this and make it super positive
and how can we turn turn churn into our
marketing engine so
beforehand if you met on a dating app
people were like we can lie and say we
met at a coffee shop so I wanted to make
sure that that was not the case and so
if you met on Bumble that became the
best marketing for us so now at a
wedding if there's Bumble stuff
everywhere because they met on Bumble
like I can't pay to get into your
wedding like I don't know how to do that
from a marketing all the time it's
amazing it does and so this churn
actually you lose one to gain five
because yes you lost a match because
they met each other and they had such a
great time and now they're you know
never going to use the dating app again
but now they've told all their friends
and they've validated it in their micro
communities which is super powerful the
second piece of that is the LTV story
around Bumble the brand we were kind of
talking about that earlier Bumble BFF
these adjacencies being in your yoga
class on the yoga mat I mean why would a
dating app do that but we were so
particular about this and we just broke
through the rules of what we were told
we could do for our category because
candidly Like Love Is All We you've got
right and relationships and and the
health of those is all we've got so I
feel like we have permission to play
Anywhere that's how I personally feel
but I might be a crazy lady so who knows
we have time for one
for one right here
hi there oh is this working okay hi um
my name is Zoe and I'm a bumble honey
for campus and thank you so much for
talking my mom's also like a huge Super
Fan so like she's right right now she
was like she was like anyway it doesn't
matter
um I guess my main question for you
um is what does bumble mean to you and
like on a more personal note like how
has a creation and like journey of your
company affected the way that you see
yourself in the broader world or your
relationships or yeah just in life so
well hi hi Mom wherever mom is
um thank you for being a bumble honey we
love you
um I bum saved me I was a broken human
when I started Bumble completely broken
so sad going through this tender stuff
um and I basically just channeled
everything I wish there was that I
didn't have into this company I just
gave it everything I didn't even know I
had in me and I had only ever had really
toxic relationships my first boyfriend
was
very very abusive when I was a young
girl like 15 16 17 years old and I just
never wanted that for any other girl out
there I just wanted to fix it and so I
basically just wished upon a star of
whatever I wish relationships looked
like and tried to just put that into
every corner of our business and so
engineering Kinder connections and
trying to make people behave better on
the internet like I live for this stuff
so Bumble is me and I am Bumble which is
probably not a good thing like literally
people are like hi Bumble girl I'm like
my I do have a name but that's okay so I
think it means everything to me and I am
I'm excited for what we can do with it
next and I just love that answer because
you know all of us have had experiences
like I think all of us sometimes have
this question around like do I have the
skill set or the background or whatever
to be an entrepreneur we all have
experiences and some of them might not
be great experiences in our life that
you can actually learn from and be able
to create into something that's going to
positively impact people in the future
and so I just I love ending on that I
think it's
so inspiring you're the best and thank
you for doing this anytime yeah Whitney
Katrina thank you so much for spending
time there's so many things you could be
doing
[Applause]
foreign